hey Bubba I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Jerry
and I'm Lauren god
welcome to reasons to see we give you a
reasons to see why not to see Daisy so
Christmas past
so let's hang out bub
so dude Jetson dude so we saw x-men Days
of Future past this film [ __ ] loved
it too definitely a favorite movie of
the year so far everything about it from
the writing and directing the
storytelling you know what I love most
about these x-men films is that you
don't really walk away thinking about
the action the action is pretty simple
and a lot of these movies actually you
really walk away thinking about the
characters [ __ ] Quicksilver dude he
was my favorite one in this whole movie
he was good he was too good so much you
kill him Evan Peters man he was odd just
every moment with him from the second
you meet him and he's playing ping pong
by himself every nuance yeah he's like a
cocky little [ __ ] I didn't love it but
his powers are so cool one and they they
make the ability to run the super fast
look awesome
yeah I mean so the time now and that was
a really great thing
oh that's almost like yes that's almost
even though he's not in the movie for a
big amount of time it's like the
opposite of what happened with gambit
it's like oh he's here for a few minutes
and it's not that engaging and here it's
like Anthony no no the next one origins
cuz there was all she can that's the
point I was making you don't remember
yeah I don't even and then this movie
it's like he's only here for a few
minutes but oh my god it's pretty rad
like I'm gonna remember that segue yeah
yeah yeah that one sequence like
everyone that's like the defining
Quicksilver moment when he breaks out
magneto and then time just slows down
and makes the guns pointing themselves I
[ __ ] himself
like moving the little bullets he's just
like a pretty you know serious movie
that adds a nice touch as well for sure
for sure man like he was incredible and
like everyone's incredible in this I
mean you got Hugh Jackman back as
Wolverine who's always solid reason to
see you do see Hugh Jackman then yeah
you know it's his ass boy yeah pretty
damn fine as a dad dude you [ __ ] his
body is incredibly like I swear you
could hear like audible gasps from the
audience I had a minor erection it was
awesome what suck Hugh Jackman's bodies
do I mean my one issue with it is that
not an issue really it's more of a wish
I had yeah that's what it is
wanna see his [ __ ] [ __ ] arena I wanted
to see more of him using his adamantium
claws to be honest I missed that when
magneto couldn't control him yeah I just
want a one fight though just one fight
with the khalipa klaus uh-huh yeah like
I like having the bone claws but the
thing is what I loved in like the x-men
show especially was when Wolverine
[ __ ] up the Sentinels and he needs
metal claws to do there yeah I wish they
had a sequence like that and just
something I don't know or are you like
[ __ ] up like the center and I was
stabbing it I remember in the first
episode of you need to stab all the
Sentinels then the movie would be over I
don't know oh and the Sentinels do they
were [ __ ] scary
the opening scene was great because it's
like action-packed but like you know all
the characters you recognize them and
the Sentinels look flippin awesome
they're awesome I love their morphing
ability yeah like - in a smart house
yeah do you do is they were terrifying
that they were like a legitimate threat
I was like oh [ __ ] these guys can really
kill these mutants when I first heard
about it like they're concluding the
robots and stuff and in the show it was
so easy for them to take on the same
yeah exactly but in this one is other
like oh man I wonder how you can really
take down a Sentinel you know they don't
have a scene where they show how you can
really take one down you've taken this
mutant extermination device to its
farthest logical you know outcome
in making it able to absorb and use yeah
powers against see it doesn't make sense
to me because then why wouldn't they use
ro guess that DNA powers oh yeah an
x-men 3 yeah
oh you own that one J he can only look
like other people but she can't hang on
other people's powers so how could they
make the Sentinels be able to do that ah
my point actually I mean I'm sure that
they you know took it a step further
with science and [ __ ] because it wasn't
just mystique it was like yeah that's
not a whole much oh yeah yeah and we're
learning something as we talk about it
how fun you don't see that under review
these days they said at this point
well rogue probably wasn't even born yet
yeah even the seventies version of the
Sentinels are pretty cool yeah yeah they
were pretty cool too and makes sense why
I might need Oh could take them down
because they hadn't meddled those time
around
memory this oh yeah the train seizure
yeah yeah how clever Michael Fassbender
in this film
Fassbender fasten bender i love him
there is not there is no end it's yes
boss bender yeah it's Fassbender
Fassbender Airbender michael phosphate
michael ass all the time in this film
dude i was like wow i liked him more
than x-men first class he wasn't like
the bad guy but he was a bad guy no one
in this film is a bad guy they just
stand by their beliefs yeah i feel like
even though he has such strong beliefs
why does he think that leg uprooting a
stadium and like killing the president
and all of his cabinet is going to make
them like mutants at some point I think
he wants to overpower and take over he
thinks mutants are the dominant race and
he views humans is basically being
scared and animalistic and they just
want to wipe us you know like they won't
so I will make them understand yeah
that's what I'm a that seems so powerful
and mystique save them because it was
like showing that hey there's some bad
mutant it's out there but there's some
good ones too aside from like the the
impending threat of the Sentinels you
don't have so much like it really clear
antagonist cuz it's just people with
conflicting ideology and like even
that's how the world works even trash
same thing like they didn't make him
like evil dude like he was just someone
who really believed like trying to say
human race yeah he was great in the film
good [ __ ] now how I think yeah when we
saw the mule last night when Peter
Dinklage came on people started laughing
correct but why are we laughing Peter
Dinklage is he short he's I think he's
great I love Jennifer Lawrence I really
do but I'm not a big fan of hers
mystique I just can't get it every time
she talked there was always something
about it I'm like this seems off it
seems like it's like a whining teenager
sometimes Rebecca oh man she's not
stable is anymore I guess I thought she
was a fantastic mystique oh yeah because
well she's got the body and she's she
like had this mysterious thing to her
and I feel like she had the body
language down better yeah she was more
like a slinky is a good word to describe
her I don't know Jennifer Lawrence was
more just like you do American yeah I
get you don't quite see how Jennifer
Lawrence's mystique becomes remains
mystique it's like you just seem like
two different people
yes I'm fine with Jennifer Lawrence's
performance and I get a lot of the
things that they have her do and why I'm
not super amped on her as mystique yeah
like I get the choices in it and I like
some of those must feel like they picked
her to be mystique because like she was
really hot at the time so they're like
let's put Jennifer Lawrence in our movie
well that movie helped her become really
hot at the time though I was like just
on the gap of her lips we're as much as
I big fan of hers mystique a lot of
critics really liked rose mystique but I
loved the ending with her like that was
a really powerful moment because this
whole time they're like really focusing
on mystique you know like the first
person she killed was Trask this is so
clever and it was all about that moment
and then when she decides not to kill
him it was like you know that's that
rare deciding to become be a good person
moment where you're like thank you I was
really hoping you wouldn't shoot him I
mean of course they had she had to do
that yeah for the sake of the movie but
there is a part of me that literally
thought like I feel like she could shoot
him actually I was a little concerned
that she wouldn't do yeah then x-men
apocalypse comes next
dude james mcavoy oh mac james mcavoy is
my favorite thing about this movie like
easily i mean my favorite part is
probably like the scene with him and
patrick stewart like staring at each
other I loved about yeah why get
everyone for the most part is really
good in this movie but his performance
especially for me anyway like there is
just so much going on with him it's it
has it's the biggest emotional journey
yeah yeah it's the most compelling
professor - Xavier performance we've
ever seen yeah because we've always seen
Professor Xavier as the wise one and
he's in control and this is the only
time that we've seen him be out of
control yeah yeah like he's pure
vulnerable in this he has no powers it's
kind of like a drug addiction he's do
yeah yeah he's a heroin addict without
being a heroin at that moment when he
decides not to inject himself with a
needle was so well acted dude all the
little subtle detail like there's just
something so flawlessly natural about
him in this movie just those times when
he drops words and things like that
those little nuances and I mean where
the story makes him go what he does with
it I just loved him yeah this whole
journey it was great that one scene that
they showed the trailer but you don't
quite know what he's talking about
yeah but he's talking a Wolverine don't
want your future and that seems so good
to man like ah then it leads into a
Patrick Stewart in him talking hey and
in question why he was bald though I
thought that's a flaw he's old like
whatever I mean if we don't really